did you guys get up to anything else on
your holidays how was your christmas
christmas
well it was supposed to be uh in
australia well that's exactly why we
went on the ski trip yeah because that
didn't happen like we've been trying to
plan a ski trip for two years
and what it took to take us to finally
plan the ski trip was a global pandemic
to cancel all our plans once again
um to be like well guys i know you guys
are free this weekend yeah or i know you
guys are finally free this week let's go
on a ski trip yeah um hopefully we'll go
on another ski trip that won't take as
much time or not two years later two
years later
uh yeah mike my christmas news was very
chill yeah spend it with some mates uh
played a lot of martial
of course you did of course is that your
new apex yeah i played with dadis and
emily a bunch so it was like addicted to
it
it's fun i don't know
it's like nfts but
i've never understood tft like it's uh
it's auto chess isn't it what does that
mean i don't [ __ ] know i it's hard to
explain right because like
it doesn't like the blockchain yeah it's
not the blockchain
it's a game that you can't easily
describe
how you describe kind of like the
blockchain
maybe maybe if god played it he's really
god's really good at giving short
descriptions to stuff i've noticed
that's why it's my job that's that's
literally what i do
i'm not when i play this game it's like
all right well it's kind of like ah
it's like a
battle simulation
chess thing you buy units and then you
place them and then it plays out on its
own the battle
so it's like tower defense but chess but
then every like it's one battle and then
you you lose health or don't miss
depending on what happens but like tower
defense is kind of like that right you
buy units and then it plays away right
yeah but you're playing against another
player oh so you're so he's buying stuff
and you're buying stuff and you're
placing them on the board right yeah and
then you go against each other and then
you have to you also get like stuff that
comes up and you it's a game gambling
but like there's like rerolling for like
more choices
it is a very boring game when you
explain it
extremely so yeah
right
again like i wouldn't recommend playing
it alone there's uh
with friends it's great yeah i think
with friends it's really fun yeah
there's a lot of way it's like chill
because it's not too intense like you
can talk like league is too intense i
feel like league like i never like i've
tried playing league with mates before
and i'm just that silent guy because i'm
like concentrating too much on the
gameplay to be able to communicate with
my friends um or like have a good time
it's great there's a lot of down time in
the game yeah you're not doing anything
so you can just chat yeah it's you can
do it very casually it's really chill
yeah it's a fun game i recommend it okay
i've been i've also have been trying to
game
i've been trying to get can i sound
anymore
but i've been trying to find a game to
get into still so kind of looking uh i
started pokemon recently the newest
pokemon oh then the switch
pokemon ever right huh is it your first
pokemon game ever it's not my first
pokemon game ever it's my first pokemon
since pokemon
ruby
the original pokemon ruby holy [ __ ] on
the like
i don't know when does pokemon get good
i've
i'll be honest because i've done like
the first two like gyms now for pokemon
diamond and i'm just like i remember
being huh that's it oh that's well
that'd be fair that's how far i go it's
like [ __ ] 10 minutes
it's like it's like two two hours two
three four hours yeah
is it really
it's i mean it's like maybe like an hour
is it there's a lot of dialogue you have
to sift through there is a lot of
dialogue a lot of like because okay
here's the thing when you go to newtown
do you talk to everyone [ __ ] no okay i
talk to everyone i'm like i'm like okay
this is he's a classic jrpg this is this
is me this is jrp
being like i have to talk to everyone
and about i can't miss the items right
about an hour and i'm just like this is
really [ __ ] boring
but why are you talking about it every
so often they give me an item so i must
talk to everyone otherwise i'm not going
to get all the items a potion yeah yeah
five five hundred of them they gave me
sometimes they give me a super potion oh
[ __ ]
it's like 500 people
how many potions do you use
your point because your pokemon's so op
that's not the point yeah i i've not
i've like not needed to change my
pokemon once since like my main pokemon
yeah i don't know like
maybe uh maybe my experience is
different from my experience as a
childhood because as a child
it was just so easy for me to immerse
myself into a game this is why pokemon
like challenges are so good and they've
got that's why people love them on
youtube like it's a way to turn a
pokemon game into a more challenging and
i suppose adult
way more fun i can't i can't play
pokemon vanilla anymore i have to make
it a chance looks so fun randomizers are
fun because because i i came into this
thinking i haven't played pokemon since
pokemon ruby i can just play this
casually and have kind of the same
experience i did as a kid yeah and i
don't know if i'm just not far enough
into the game yet but i mean to me like
two three hours into a game is like
mostly most of the time that's what i
give a game before i'm just like do i
stick with this game and fully commit or
do i try another game i think you like
the game gun maybe maybe i don't maybe i
don't maybe you should try a nuzlocke
version of it that'd be more fun what's
the mazlock again nuzlocke is like
permadeath basically oh so if you're
pokemon fades you die it dies quote
unquote and you have to release it and
you can only catch one pokemon in one
area there's lots of different rules
it's really good there's lots of local
rules as well you can you can kind of
mix it up with like different other
rules why wouldn't you just if your
pokemon's gonna die why wouldn't you
just like grind like crazy well i mean
some people do but the challenge but
then there's a challenge element of like
do i want to grind for 50 hours or do i
just want to like gamble and go for a
lot of the time people aren't willing to
grind for 20 hours just to secure their
pokemon well it's more fun and on stream
it's very good it's very good
it sounds like great stream content that
just sounds stressful to me it is
stressful yeah
that looks a hell stress i saw someone
do uh one pp challenge what's that great
name
every pokemon they're only allowed to
use the move once oh [ __ ] in like one
battle i think yeah yeah unless it heals
up again right yeah yeah there's there's
some pretty [ __ ] obscure challenges
and there's the soul link which looks
really good um basically like where you
both of you do another together and like
if joey's pokemon dies when we caught it
at the same time my pokemon dies too
yeah
do you think pokemon should have a
difficulty setting i think they should
just well i don't know why they haven't
had their own nuzlocke into the [ __ ]
game just call it whatever they want to
call it they'll they'll remove their
name nuzzle because it's pokemon they
won't they don't give credit to anyone
yeah but i don't know why they haven't
put it in the game people do it because
it's at the end of the day it's still a
children's game yeah but like
people are doing this to their games
anyway and people are going to do it why
not just add the option like it's not
that it's a children's game
but like surely adding like the
especially like a randomizer right
surely that's easy to add oh yeah just
go in the code be like random all right
and yeah it should work right super easy
i know because like for me i've never i
never got the pokemon conversation
before because i just hadn't played a
pokemon in so [ __ ] long but now that
i've now now that i've started to play
i'm just like
when does like when does this get fun
how long how long do i not need to be on
autopilot for before this is yeah it's
because
you're playing normally i think if you
tried another lock on on a stream you'd
enjoy it a lot but i i like if i'm not
supposed to play it normally as a casual
player who knows zero about pokemon
controlled for that
am i am i too old for that corner you've
played too many games you know how to
game so i'm not even a gamer i'm not
even a gamer i'm not jrpgs right yeah i
played like grinding for like 15 hours
to like get one sash or something i
don't know yeah you're too good you're
totally not a jrvg player you're you're
too good at like grinding yeah but and
pokemon now actually doesn't require any
grinding you can just do it like you'll
start a pokemon stomps when did that
happen i remember in the original
pokemon as a kid i had to like grind the
[ __ ] out like even just like the first
two
first two gym
no black and white they didn't have it i
think it was x and y it was always an
item but it always only gave it to one
pokemon yeah yeah and then now they just
they were like [ __ ] it just turn it on
for everyone you get experience by
catching pokemon as well which was never
a thing yeah you get experienced by
catching people when you catch a pokemon
yeah the pokemon in your party get
experience yeah yeah as if you as if you
defeated it yeah they just they just
[ __ ] they're just oprah winfrey and
[ __ ] dxp this is like you're getting
xp you get exp
like
as as as a gacha gamer i'm disgusted by
the lack of grinding i need to do in
this game
like
as a gamer i'm disgusted by you guys
yeah i have been thinking to do maybe
like shiny runs or like uh you know like
stuff like that where it's like a little
more challenging you know yeah
yeah
yeah the really a really fun one i did
was uh i did like a pokemon emerald mod
where when and whenever you enter a
building it teleports you to a random
part of the map oh yeah i've seen that
one that one was really fun but because
it was so [ __ ] hard because you had
to like route everything
on your own yeah so if you weren't
familiar with the map of the game you
were just [ __ ] true
that was really fun though because it's
like it gives on a completely different
challenge to it yeah it actually becomes
like really entertaining and fun
so are all new pokemon games just this
easy unless you like they all
artificially add difficulty to your own
run yeah okay i'd say ever since like
black and white or x and y is where it's
really started like hold your hand i
honest i understand gamers now
i thought you guys were being babies
complaining about this
actually it actually holds your hand now
it's like
especially if you've played pokemon ever
since the beginning yeah yeah i i go
from that which is like if you catch a
pokemon you need to commit to leveling
it up oh dude like kids if i want to
give a kid today who grew up on like
sword and shield yeah like the new
remakes give them like the original blue
or like red and black play this game and
yeah watch them like have a mental
breakdown of how difficult it is
compared to what they get today did you
did you see the uh [ __ ] what was it
called [ __ ] um i totally forgot no sorry
oh
great
[Music]
yeah no because i remember as a kid i
don't know it's it like some things just
felt rewarding that i don't feel
rewarded with this game for example when
you level up your pokemon every pokemon
just levels up automatically yeah it's
like it's like an auto leveler yeah
it was the pokemon let's go even pikachu
oh yeah yeah yeah they gave your starter
pokemon like increased stance the eevee
or pikachu and it had a special move
yeah just one shot everything yeah they
gave they gave you like a starter they
could just one shot no the most [ __ ]
part about evie i really enjoyed evie to
be fair but like the most [ __ ] part
about evie was uh i did an eevee only
run on stream once because it's just so
[ __ ] easy but like in in some of the
pokemons you go to there's just this
dude who's like i can teach your eevee
any move of any type
for free which one would you like
it's like fire move and it's like and
they're like really [ __ ] powerful
moves as well so it's like ah
what's the catch it's like no catch
it's because you talked to me it was
like
oh good and i did i think i did the
eevee only run like four hours it was
like one of the easiest [ __ ] games
ever
i only did it because i like evie so
when it's like was it after pokemon ruby
that everything started to just get easy
because
the original diamond pearl was still
like in that same difficulty range right
i think i reckon it was around like x
and y like 6th gen where where they
introduced like the whole like
experience sharing and like the really
like holding your hand on because sun
and moon was just so like ridiculously
easy right same with sword and shield as
well and then every every other remake
since then it's just been like baby mode
i remember when i was a kid in the games
this is like boomer when i was uh back
in my day back in my every game was just
[ __ ] impossible [ __ ] yeah right but
now we've gone too far
i remember crying trying to beat the
first stage of mega man 2. you know i
ride a game on game boy right it was
dalmatians 101
hardest [ __ ] game ever played in my
life
the disney games like game boy advance
were so hard not even game boy it's like
game boy oh game boy oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
was impossible i didn't know what the
[ __ ] i was doing like this is this is
how [ __ ] games were back then like yeah
i didn't even didn't even tell you the
objective yeah you just have to go
around and figure [ __ ] out you don't
know what kills you i don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on i don't i don't
even
i don't i don't even see qualityville in
that game i was just going around this
[ __ ] thing i remember this boss right
it was like a construction site and i
was i was one of the [ __ ] dogs and i
was like why is this [ __ ] and i remember
like accordions were killing me like
what is this game like i i just don't
understand like back then they used to
put [ __ ] was it one of those like
unlicensed disney games no no it was an
actual license oh my god this is back
where like licensed games are just like
just uh just put a platformer and just
make it impossible yeah just
yeah it was back then where it was like
take the ip put it into the mario
universe change the [ __ ] design a
little bit you have a game
so that's what the mickey mouse game was
the one that i scammed to my friend
basically it was like stup it was
basically just a mario platformer but it
was stupidly hard i'm sure i had this
like ps1 game and it was like a shrek
game
it was like a shrek
uh
a shrek picnic game or something
right
and i'm sure shrek enthusiasts can
inform you about this game right right
remember the whole point of this game
was to like
you were assembling like i i could be
describing this completely correctly
like the parts to your picnic
yeah and you had to go and like beat
bosses and [ __ ] but like nothing worked
in the game i remembered
i have to i have to look this up okay
can we communicate
it doesn't sound like a real game shrek
of ps1 games okay google it right shrek
i just remember it's like a fever dream
in this game the polygons were so the
shriek treasure hunt that's it that's it
this game right i played this game oh my
god there was like one polygon in this
whole that looks like arsed what is that
what is this game
what is it
actually has good ratings yeah it's 78
like this video game what is it
what what what's the synopsis can we
read the synopsis
treasure hunt
uh
is preparing a gameplay
with fiona the three blind mice steal
all the picnic equipment such as foods
and drinks so shrek must go on an
adventure doing mini games to get the
items back before fiona arrives
but i remember it was like a bunch of
mini games right and these mini games
just like all broken up they didn't work
i love games with these kinds of shitty
plots because you can just imagine it
just being like fiona i have to go get
it i showed them
the camera was like unusable and it kept
breaking my ps1
and then eventually it like just broke
and i was so close to the end of this
game i was distraught yeah what's the
last picnic item i couldn't believe it i
remember you have to go like some castle
or something to fight these [ __ ] mice
or some nonsense like that and i was
just so angry that i couldn't finish it
i have to i have to find that and play
it you gotta play it right sounds
amazing it's a great game it's [ __ ] you
just stream it i guess i should maybe
i'll stream it if you want me to
i want to see it